roux compte moi je suis totalement
contre le pass annie terre on va diviser
les frères c'est bravo des bons et des
mauvais citoyens bah moi je serais un
mauvais citoyen racing gènes du cinéma
parce que je l'est pas ben je rentrerai
par derrière comme si on m'empêche de
maçon restaurant va s'aimer ça on va
vous reconnaitre moi j'irai je ne veux
pas de ce pass annie terre il ya une
seule catégorie de français et il ya des
gens qui veulent se faire vacciner qui
peuvent pas encore donc je dis non pas
célèbres avatars des rapaces au premier
de la classe du visuel les suceurs du
coni de là les trois là on en parlera
d'après juge au pôle amont d'abord mais
il est 6 heures du coup vite oui bah oui
ou non - jean leray milliards une femme
arrêt j'ai beaucoup de succès quand je
raconte l'histoire de la femme qui va
chercher de l'arsenic les pharmaciens
oui tu te fais j'ai beaucoup de succès
avec cette histoire là la très bien mais
j'en ai doute s'avérer payant ils ont
toujours des blagues un peu salace est
bon est donc tout à fait dans ce créneau
mais mais mais là quand quand vous êtes
anti masques et anti vaccin là moi je
suis pas daccord des gentils quand ils
passent mais en type aussi anti vaccins
c'est parce que j'ai bientôt l'interview
vous avez fait devant radio poutine là
c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu'il ya eu on
a eu un lot là on a eu droit à des toits
de chaume et droit où on a eu le droit à
l'anti vaccin qui est un poison qui est
une merde etc
là franchement là je suis pas d'accord
et le pass sanitaire vous savez votre
téléphone portable
on sait exactement où vous êtes on sait
exactement où vous avez pas deux mais
trois non c'est vrai un 6/6 stores sion
c'est dans la rue vous êtes dans la rue
filmé en direct et vous allez payer avec
vous allez avec votre carte vitale on
sait exactement ce que vous avez pris on
sait exactement ce que vous avez pris
comme médicament quel médecin vous devez
vue et c'est donc question fichage ya
pas de problème on est déjà largement
fait le pass sanitaire ne pas sanitaire
savoir que quand vous allez dans un
autre pays
vous êtes vacciné que le pays qui vous
accueille il sait que étant vaccinez
vous n'irez pas inonder les encombrer
les réanimations de ce pays parce
qu'elle soit parce qu'on est toujours
contaminants même sans élection alors
justement non justement semble sympa ça
on le savait pas encore et encore il ya
très peu de temps olivier v revient que
le dire il ya une étude israélienne qui
me olivier variant il change tout le
temps tout et il ya une étude il n
utilise malienne qui montre clairement
que les gens vaccinés transmettent peu
le virus et que et que et c'est à ce
qu'il dit lui
ouais l'embassy ça je peux vous le dire
et puis ensuite en mai vous ce que vous
m'aimiez et en 2010 est santé ça s'est
super je suis pas je suis pas tout ce
que dit mr est ce que vous pensez
d'inoculer avec 5 qui n'a pas subi les
essais cliniques
disons ils ont fait alors là je peux
vous dire qu'ils ont fait où les essais
cliniques n'avait pas du tout aller ne
sera terminée qu'en 2022 de toute façon
on va continuer de surveiller les effets
de ce vaccin mais tous les effets là ce
qui est clair
ce rapport va continuer de surveiller
vous avez dit quand même extraordinaire
c'est que les gens grâce à la rn message
et ils ont réussi à faire un vaccin en
deux mois la prouesse technique qui a
été fait et les agences de surveillance
du médicament
on surveillait au jour le jour c'est à
dire que d'habitude vous faites les
phases 1 face de phase iii faouët et
vous remettez tout et elle a touché
leurs deux mois non ils ont fait ça au
coup par coup c'est à dire que les
agences ont surveillé les résultats de
la phase 1
ils ont surveillé les résultats de la
phase 2 ils ont surveillé les routes à
la phase iii et au moment où ils ont ils
ont même fait les trois huit en europe
pour valider les tests qui avaient été
donnés à la fin donc c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont travaillé de façon
extraordinaire techniquement c'est
formidable uniquement là aujourd'hui à
tokyo et les gens qui nous regardent si
vous affirmez que les essais cliniques
sont fait les essais cliniques sont
faits oui ils sont celles au diable eu
aucun danger sont pas finis a on a
participé un protocole de recherche
médicale il y as que moi la relève trop
c'est leur lettre e cycle avec la ou les
suspects n'ont jamais été vérifiées
évidemment je m'y oppose on sait il ya
combien combien millions personnes qui
ont été qui ont été vaccinées on sait
qu'il ya des effets secondaires pour un
corps suis renseigné les morts sur 120
milles et il ya un décès pour un peu
moins d'un million donc ça il ya un
décès beau 36000 vacciner c'est sur
l'échelle
1 les quais très peu mais pas comme pour
la grippe qu'elle a été et est passé par
tous les essais cliniques 1 à 0 je s'il
vous plaît alors que là il ya quand même
il ya quand même une petite malchance
sur place ou prêt à jouer jean marie
jean marie on parle du passage du ter
guillaume genton vous êtes d'accord pour
vous voyez je suis contre le passé
militaire deuxième ce qui ne respectent
pas la liberté de chacun de vous obliger
un règlement nous faire vacciner il ya
des millions de français comme gilles je
remarque qu'ils ne veulent pas se faire
vacciner
montage et la malice énuméra qui va
contrôler les passes pas rentrer dans
les restaurants c'est un vigile sais pas
où est ce que vous seriez peut-être
demain ou quand on voyage est ce que
c'est le rôle des salariés de contrôler
n'est pas de sanitaires donc moi je
pense qu'il est à la fois utopique et
liberticide ce se passe a dit à nous
mettre une puce comme mon petit chat et
la souris mais des immédiatement
identifié situé vacciner ou pas quel but
poursuivent le d'en bas moi je n'ai moi
je dis clairement non parce qu'à partir
du moment où ce qu'a dit gilles tout à
l'heure on n'a même pas assez de vaccins
donc même pour ceux qui voudraient se
faire vacciner mois par an que j'ai mon
père qui cherche depuis deux semaines et
qui trouve pas vous rendez compte
travesti chaque dans son jardin risque
pas de siège dans toute la région et
c'est ça le problème c'est qu'à partir
du moment où on veut imposer quelque
chose déjà il faut être en capacité de
le proposer
et deuxièmement c'est exactement qu'est
ce que ce que ce que guillaume me disais
c'est qu'à un moment donné mais on va
pouvoir qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir faire
la fête entre les parties dans les
restaurants et non pas le débrayage mais
non allez on va s'intéresser aux
premiers de la classe
j'ai juste quelque chose à dire 45 on a
en plateau le problème c'est que aucun
médecin n'est d'accord donc aujourd'hui
on nous met des guillemets demande en
aura il est là le problème c'est que les
médecins sont pas d'accord entre eux
les accords sur la vaccination beaucoup
beaucoup les jours
du coup s'il vous plaît merci ben halima
enchères mais encore une fois personne
ne vous oblige à vous vacciner si vous
avez bien sûr tu peux rien faire pour
terminer ma farine le pass sanitaire
c'est où le vaccin ou un test pcr
négatif où vous avez eu la corrida donc
si vous ne voulez pas vous vacciner vous
allez faire votre test si vous êtes
négatif vous allez où vous voulez donc
donc donc ya pas de songer
donc il y avait eu pression j'ai bouffé
de m raymond bachand remettre le carré
là avec tous les trucs qui sont
interdits ou à lyon n'a pas aussi bon
voilà vous avez beau c'est parce que moi
en fait le passé ni terre et je veux
dire il me ramène moi je sais pas trop
troisième bras moi non plus je fais pas
de croisière mais il me ramène à toute
la discrimination quand j'étais plus
jeune avec mes potes jérôme famille
farouk tony on voulait aller en boîte et
on pouvait pas aller en boîte entre est
pas en boîte et je me disais ce matin
avec john farouk tony plusieurs mac et
on rentrait pas en boîte et j'ai musclé
et je me disais c'est donc un mec décide
j'ai travaillé toute la semaine j'ai 18
ans et un le maître va décider si le
droit de m'amuser là quand je vois
festival en plein air
si moi j'ai pas envie d'avoir un pass
sanitaire ça veut dire que je peux pas
aller non cavalaire au bord de la mer
ont gardé un festival en plein air je
vois pas aller presse dans un théâtre
ans je peux parler dans un établissement
sportif comme aller au casino
je vais pas au casino je peux pas aller
dans un rassemblement de plus
l'animateur
ton salon sénat le 19 juin
ouais je le fais à 999 personnes parce
que de larges et je réponds la salutaire
suivirent les gens qui dote de tous ceux
qui travaillent ici j'étais avec eux
tout à l'heure je les connais presque
tous pas de 7 ans l'heure nous on n'a
pas eu l'ombre d'un écrivain ans oui me
disent mais si je suis pas vacciné je
peux pas travailler
bien sûr je veux juste finir parce qu'en
plus ils nous ont expliqué tout à
l'heure dans la notice là que vous avez
envoyé là le reportage à vous avez dit
en plus si vous voulez voyager sous
réserve de certains pays qui vous
demanderont quand même une quarantaine à
cause du variant mais à dire quoi le
pastis à rien parce qu'on va te mettre
quand même en quarantaine d'actes blanc
sais pas si tu sais que tu attrapes
quand même avis tu te retrouves en
quarantaine dans un hôtel
jean-paul rien alors jean paul hamon si
on fonce et quand même si ce sont quand
même d'aider des préoccupations vraiment
de de luxe quoi non non c'est pas du
luxe
[Applaudissements]
les stades c'est l'âme des gens
sincèrement
sincèrement je peux vous dire que les
soignants les médecins en majorité ce
sont vaccinés d'entrée de jeu et après
il a fallu discuter avec les infirmières
et avec les aides soignants mais mais
mais mais je peux vous dire que ça c'est
c'est absolument indispensable si on
veut continuer à mener une vie normale
80% mais c'est à dire c'est obligatoire
attend 80 % des français veulent se
faire vacciner 75 118
je comprends pas où est votre père là
parce que vraiment c'est quand même à
fait dans la soirée c'est précisément la
preuve s'il en est
quand j'enseignais le temps
deux files heures ne se fait pas
beaucoup alors ça ta vraie c'est
totalement ça il n'a pas pu participer à
la fête de l'indépendance d'israël parce
que il n'est civile ne se fait pas m
sont la preuve accent là et et
j'aimerais que ça rigolait bien sûr et
tu sais tout
[Rires]
m
cctc les knicks ont fait et le patron de
pfizer s'est fait vacciner parce que
tino signal actuellement il n'y a plus
aucune restriction sanitaire parce que
les gens sont en majorité baxi mais il
suffirait que 80 il fait 10 ans quand on
va attendre des 80 la actuellement on
vaccine à peu près 10 millions de
personnes par mois
j'espère que ça va s'accélérer et que
d'ici la fin de l'été on sera peinard
mais c'est vrai que si on voudra le ce
qui restera du passani terre il ne
restera rien quand les gens seront
vaccinés quand on commencera à respirer
enfin mélasse actuellement ça descend on
est à 3500 personnes en réanimation il
ya douze ou treize mille personnes qui
sont contagieuses que l'immunité
collective de dj son immunité collective
mais on a été un petit peu il ya quand
même trente mille personnes qui ont reçu
30 millions personnes qui ont reçu pas
mis en personne qui ont reçu une
première dose et et 10 millions qui sont
qui sont totalement vacciner avec les
avec la le confinement convient de
connaître avec avec le lait les beaux
jours enfin pas en ce moment
non il était dehors qu'à l'intérieur on
peut errer le risque de contamination
est plus faible mais mais mais on ne
gagnera pas la bataille si on ne se
vaccinent pas massivement